[Music]
it's Santa
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well I
guess it's Stephen King time again yes
this is the first time I've ever done to
Stephen King videos in the same month so
it probably goes without saying I need
alcohol luckily I have the Stephen King
drinking game shot glasses yeah no joke
a fan made these for me and I can't
think of a better time to use them so
let's get ready to talk about yet
another Stephen King adaptation this is
the top eleven Stephen King good movies
good movies you mean I finally get to
talk about good Stephen King movies good
movies I'm still gonna drink this four
years of me fund the Stephen King's
worse adaptations running cliches may be
passed over the good stuff that made him
popular to begin with truth be told this
guy has written not only some amazing
stories but amazing stories that turn
into amazing films on top of that
they're different types of films some
big and over-the-top some subtle and
perplexing some scary some funny some
standards and some ground breakers that
inspire filmmakers to change the field
they're in as much as I mock is funnier
stuff King has turned in some game
changers that force us to think deeper
about what scares us what moves us what
pushes us apart and what pulls us closer
together it's been a long time coming
but I finally get to discuss some of the
greatest works of one of our most famous
writers and we're gonna talk about the
top eleven of them here today my top
eleven because I like to go one step
beyond so sit back and enjoy the top
eleven good can still feel so weird to
say Stephen King movies
[Music]
number eleven Pet Sematary this has
creepy written all over it
from the book and the screenplay both
penned by King focusing on a family who
just moved into town they discover a
cemetery where you can bury a dead
animal and it miraculously comes to life
like any cautionary tale though it dooms
those who try to mess with the natural
order of things for those buried there
come back looking the same but acting
different somehow a completely new soul
than what went into the ground when a
family member is tragically killed they
attempt to do the same thing only this
time the differences are even more clear
and disturbing the entire film has a
surreal sense of dread every shot seems
to echo with deathly air and
uncomfortable anxiety the film only
promises to get stranger and stranger
and that's exactly where it leads us
never knowing quite where it's going or
even how to feel during some of these
scenes Pet Sematary feels like a creepy
fable that's both haunting in his moral
as well as its visuals it leaves you
with goose bumps all over your body and
being thankful that whatever becomes
dead stays dead
[Music]
number ten
it okay so I've made fun of both filmed
versions and I do still have issues with
them but there's no denying that the
cinematic version of it had some big
shoes to fill
Wow and it did so in its own unique way
the story of a group of kids coming
across a killer clown that can transform
into their deepest fears tie some
beautifully to all the real-life fears
that these kids have to deal with in the
regular lives some of them are pretty
common like creepy paintings and
monsters but some are even scarier
without the supernatural like obsessive
phobias psychotic teens and more than
abusive parents the film taps into the
scares both kids and adults would have
and at the center is a completely new
Pennywise the clown played with a
completely new energy by bill skarsgård
the roll was made iconic by Tim Curry
but the film did a great job creating a
brand new kind of creepiness both scary
and faithful to the book while also
being its own unique creation yeah I had
some issues if you want to know more
about them you can watch my review but
as I let it sit good stuff does get
better and better asking questions about
the fears of the mind the fears of the
physical and how they intersect but come
on can't you have him tell a few jokes
well you better let the poor guy up
number nine
14:08 this is one of the few films that
visually captures the writing of Stephen
King style don't get me wrong many other
films do their best and accomplish great
visuals but something about the pacing
effects and blending of reality seems to
scream King's writing prose a man who
writes books debunking the supernatural
is told about a haunted hotel room
numbered 1408 the room is so haunted
that the owner of the hotel tries to
bribe anyone from staying in it
the writer sees this as a stunt though
and it says he'd be leaded what follows
is a slow descent into madness never
knowing if what he's seeing or even
doing is reality or his own mind messing
with him the film is very clever in not
just having monsters from his past come
out and go boo but slowly and
effectively morphing from one point in
time to another point in time combining
his past and future to make an awful
present this eventually seems to even
put his loved ones in danger and leaving
him seemingly no way out you feel this
room you feel how it traps in both
physically and psychologically after a
while you yourself don't know what's
real is he talking to someone or is he
just talking to himself did he make it
outside or is he still in the room are
others really in danger or is it just
himself after a while you can't figure
out if it's been minutes or years he's
been trapped in this hell but either way
it feels like an eternity
this film captures a books ability to
keep you in a moment in time only in
this circumstance you feel trapped by it
very few movies can do that and this one
does an incredible job it's a terrifying
trip they'll have you asking the
question where are you right now
[Music]
all right
carry the classic story of why you don't
pick on the quiet kid carry stars a
tortured teen who is constantly torn
down by her mother the kids at school
pretty much everyone around her little
do they know that she seems to have
telekinesis but even she herself doesn't
know how they work or when they work
things seem to look up though when she
goes to the prom is crowned prom queen
but then discovers it's a cruel prank to
humiliate her
do I even need to say what happens next
the climax to Carrie is so famous and
referenced so much it's ingrained in our
popular culture and the great thing is
even if you know this going in Carrie is
loaded with tragic moments disturbing
imagery and a hope that this quiet girl
will for once get a break when she never
does though you can easily understand
why this third act is as effective as it
is Carrie used an experimental
split-screen editing that was used only
in a handful of films at the time this
might seem a little gimmicky it's
surprisingly effective in a film like
this adding to the uncomfortable nature
of what you're watching even with the
option of two shots there's nowhere you
can look that isn't showing someone's
suffering
lots of people had tried to replicate
the idea tone and overall creep value
that carrie has created but even with
all the imitators there's only one carry
only one carry it's uncomfortable
it's Yui is a painful to life from
beginning to end
pleasant dreams and remember
[Music]
misery it's every celebrities nightmare
being held hostage by a crazy fan who's
virtually impossible to please a famous
writer gets in a car crash and is picked
up by a seemingly kind in timid fan once
she reads his latest book though she
reveals a psychotic monster who can't
stand the idea of her favorite character
being dead she not only forces him to
write a follow-up book but she locks him
in the house cuts off all the phone
lines and even breaks his legs all in
the name of love the story brilliantly
shows not just the physical torture she
puts him through but the mental torture
as well as he has to burn some of his
favorite writings as well as find out
more and more how crazy his caretaker is
and constantly navigate through her
crazy mood swings to please her and
survive all the while he's writing this
book that she constantly checks to make
sure it meets her standards the internet
was made for a fan like this the payoff
of writing the book works out to a
revenge that's so sweet and so fitting I
dare not ruin it here nevertheless it
ties into the obsessive nature of some
fan cultures that as I said before far
removed from current fan cultures the
nice thing is it's a cautionary tale for
both sides the creator and the fan with
the fan we see how crazy someone can
push an obsession and with a creator we
see writing for the heart as opposed to
please your crowd can have pros and cons
that you have to be ready to deal with
well maybe not this extreme hopefully
and kind and quiet too brash and loud
this film runs the insanity up to 11
from spinal tap which Rob Reiner also
directed now that's a comparison
[Music]
no assets
stand by me Reiner
I guess has a way with King stories as
this is the second big hit he's done
with him although boy it could have been
more different from misery its
coming-of-age story centers around a
group of boys all dealing with their own
problems getting together to find a dead
body not the most uplifting of missions
but it's not always the most uplifting
of films like most Kings stories the
kids in this have a lot of shit they
have to get through and it's their
ability to stick together shoot the shit
that just be a friend when there's so
few that gets them through it the film
certainly has a lot of positive moments
as well with a lot of jokes chases and
tough life lessons the acting in this is
stellar and it's no wonder with such an
amazing cast of then unknowns
Wil Wheaton Corey Feldman River Phoenix
Kiefer Sutherland everyone gives the
exact right performance in this
aggressive story of childhood that still
manages to dig through the harshness and
turn out some very human moments the
kinship these kids develop is strong
memorable yet simple it's being there
for one another because no one else is
and sometimes when you do that you find
you want to be there for that person too
no matter how strange or troubled they
might be it's a collection of friends
and moments that makes this story one
hell of an unforgettable adventure
[Music]
you
Dolores Claiborne often overlooked this
crime drama once again uses the sins of
the past to shape the tragedy of the
present a daughter revisits her hometown
of painful memories to help her mother
Dolores Claiborne who was accused of
murder as if this wasn't bad enough this
is the second time she's been accused of
it in her life well the daughter has
tried to distance herself from her
mother she finds the doors in her memory
are constantly opened up the longer she
spends both with her mother and in her
childhood home as she talks more and
more to find the true she discovers so
many things she got wrong about her
mother and even all the facts she
repressed things she didn't remember
because she didn't want to remember them
and while they're painful to open up
again they're necessary to open up again
not only are the performances and this
painfully good but the way the film
switches from past and present is so
smoothly done and flawless sometimes
you'll forget what time period you're in
for a minute
feeding into the themes of the movie
it's the type of King story that sadly
doesn't get a ton of attention but I
really think he does beautifully trying
to reconcile where you came from with
who you are and learning to punish or
forgive those who made you that way
it's glanced over a lot but doesn't
deserve to be if you haven't seen it yet
give it a watch it's really something
powerful
[Music]
the shawshank redemption' a different
kind of King film to say the least but a
powerful one the movie centers around
Andy Dufresne a man sentenced to jail
for killing his wife and her lover
he's befriended by another prisoner
named red and the film follows the pain
torture but ultimately friendship
through surviving the harsh realities of
prison with the persistence of hope the
film doesn't shy away from the difficult
things Dufresne goes through including
sexual assault I also like that
technically they don't say whether or
not Dufresne committed the murder though
there's certainly having large leanings
to be honest I probably have liked this
film even more if they kept that more of
a mystery you had to make the choice
whether or not he did it and how much
you can be on his side still the film
focuses on people that society is given
up on and arguably for good reasons but
demonstrates there can still be a
humanity that binds people together
despite a constant fight to not have it
stripped away it be so easy just to make
this a simple good guys wrongly accused
film but everyone in that jail is there
for a reason
so even if you see Dufresne is innocent
what about the other guys what about all
the other people are they all wrongly
accused what about the warden he's on
the side of good yet he does some
terrible things how are you supposed to
feel about a lot of these people but in
the end it almost doesn't matter as to
stay sane they're forced to find the
goodness and camaraderie in each other
no matter what they did it's a
challenging idea to make us sympathize
this much with them but again it doesn't
shy away from the bad stuff they do
either this movie is all about
connections for sound necessity then out
of friendship and I've even kind of back
to necessity again because when you go
through this much with a friend they do
become a necessity much like the rain on
your face it's one hell of a cold
cleansing
[Music]
Gerald's gave this Netflix film had a
tough story to adapt but thankfully it
had a great director to do so fie thing
is it's not the traditional kind of
horror you would expect from King the
movie starts as a couple tried to spice
up their love life by using handcuffs in
the bedroom the guy dies leaving the
woman handcuffed to the bed far away
from anyone that can hear her that's the
entire movie you'd think that couldn't
be very interesting but the way she
makes other versions of herself to talk
to imagines her loved one coming back to
life hallucinates terrifying imagery and
even reopens memories of a scarring
incident makes this one of the most
brilliant King movies ever made it's
funny how his best stories revolve
around one person just lying in bed but
that truly is a tribute to his talent he
doesn't need much just a clever scenario
and really great characters to go along
with it the story cleverly questions how
much scarring can be left on a person
without touching them how much of those
mental scars are real
how much do you let them affect you and
how much of them do you address the film
even cleverly has a callback to Dolores
Claiborne if you know the story you know
there's actually a very surreal
connection made again all the more
reason to check both of these two out
the way this film's questions tie into
one of the hallucinations she sees in
the room is so brilliantly done that it
makes the ending all the more powerful
meaningful and in my opinion probably
the deepest of any story King is written
again I won't go into spoilers you just
got to see it yourself this is a very
difficult book to adapt especially the
ending which many may feel is tagged on
at first but really think about how it
connects to her past her present and
even her future when you think about it
long enough it's actually kind of
ingenious in my opinion the movie
Gerald's game is an adaptation worthy of
its great source material
[Music]
the shining funny how one of kings most
famous films as one he dislikes and to
his credit it's not really hard to see
why this adaptation of the shining gets
the basics of the book right
it's a caretaker who looks after a hotel
in the winter with his family get snowed
in and goes insane trying to kill them
all King disliked however how there was
little arc to the main character on how
I felt less like a tragedy it's very
understandable especially from the guy
who wrote the original story but the
shining to me anyway is less about a guy
being driven to madness and more about a
crazy guy being stripped away for what
he really is the whole film has an
otherworldly feel that only master
director Stanley Kubrick could create
the pacing the tone the cold delivery of
many of the actors it's like the hotel
is a drug slowly working down your
defenses until you have no filters left
and there's only the real you much like
another drug in the movie you could
argue that the hotel is a metaphor for
bringing out who you really are
Jack was always that way he was always
there he was always the caretaker it
just took a diabolical something to
bring it out but the nice thing is
that's just my take there's literally
dozens of other interpretations of the
film so many that a film interpreting
the film was made with a bunch of other
thoughts of what it's about regardless
of what it means it creates an
environment that's strange
uncomfortable haunting and leaves it up
to you to decide what's going on leaving
the real fear to your own imagination
you can't even count how many people
have satirized this movie it's truly
left its mark on audiences and
filmmakers and its popularity doesn't
seem to be dying down everything Stanley
Kubrick did was unique and this is his
only horror film making it a rare
spectacle nobody will ever forget
before we get to number one here's some
honorable mentions and here we go and
the number one Stephen King movie is
you're not gonna like it you're really
not gonna like it
look just hear me out before you go
ranting about why I'm wrong you are I
have a paragraph in the comments don't
you oh right oh right I'll just say it
it's Creepshow now you might be saying
to yourself why why Creepshow it's not
an emotional powerhouse like stand by me
or Shawshank it's just an anthology
movie of scary stories there's a ton of
those yes there are but there are no
anthologies nay no movies anything like
Creepshow from the stories to the style
to the actors to the colors this is the
most unique blend of elements that
should not work but somehow work
brilliantly
if you said George a Romero's wants
cartoons in his scary movie it'd be seen
as nuts if you said weird colorful
glowing backgrounds appear at random for
seemingly no reason as well as comic
book panels on the side it'd be seen as
nuts if you said as actor Stephen King
can make you laugh eg Marshall can make
you paranoid and Leslie Nielsen can be
one of the greatest villains ever put on
screen who are you kidding
all of that is destined for failure but
it all comes together like no other film
it can go from big scares to small
scares from loud and gory to sinister
and psychological from psychotic to
hilarious it's somehow all mixes
together in the craziest of ways I can't
think of another film that has a
suspense story of mostly people talking
that suddenly goes to neon colors with
the straight face villain laughing like
a loon and it all somehow fits perfectly
they tried to replicate this in other
movies some were even pretty good but
nothing was ever as insanely unique as
Creepshow it truly is one of a kind the
meshing of styles genres and scares all
played to the opposite sides of the
spectrum and almost manding ly balance
out it should have succeeded it should
have been one of the dumbest things with
Stephen King's name on it but because it
went all the way combining great
instinct with great technique we've got
a film that has never been duplicated
Shawshank is great but we can think of a
few other films like it Stand By Me is
wonderful but again we can think of a
couple films it's like there is no other
movie like Creepshow but simply it's one
of a kind I've seen it a million times
in the past and I know I'm gonna see it
a million times more Creepshow is the
best kind of madness that only strikes
once and you're thankful you were there
to witness something so bizarrely
perfect it's somehow it gets better the
crazier it gets I've never seen anything
like Creepshow and my guess is I never
yes so weird to talk so positive for so
long but that's it are there any I left
out we'll leave them in the comments
below and let people know which ones
deserve more attention I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout-out in this week we are doing the
fortune Society the fortune societies
mission is to support successful
re-entry from incarceration and promote
alternatives to incarceration thus
strengthening the fabric of our
communities with over 50 years of
experience under its belt the fortune
Society has become one of the nation's
leading re-entry service organizations
serving nearly 7,000 individuals
annually it's also a leading advocate in
the fight for criminal justice reform
and alternatives for incarceration
Fortunes program models are recognized
both nationally and internationally for
their quality and innovation and
continues to inspire and transform a
multitude of lives their alternatives to
incarceration have saved taxpayers
eleven million dollars and their
employment services placed over 680
people and new jobs if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you see so
many people released from prison have a
very slim chance of starting over the
fortune steps in and makes sure that
they're given the same rights every
human being deserves
and see how you can help those who have
done their time start over in the right
way
[Music]
you